ladies and gentlemen 50 v8 for one
sector I have been asked by the Academy
to make the following statement
regarding a statement that was made by a
winner the Academy is saying quote we
are not responsible for any political
references on this program and we are
sorry that they had to take place this
evening
No you know what the movie South Pacific
the bridges at toko-ri sayonara and
Hawaii have in common they were all
based on novels written by the man whose
current bestseller is continental I mean
centennial he is a pure lat surprise
winner who has come here tonight present
the writing Awards
mr. James Michener
I am often asked why the Oscar does not
go to the writer of the original book
the answer is simple the difference
between a book to be read and a shooting
script from that book is monumental it
is proper that the man or woman who
makes this transformation should get the
Oscar for the best adaptation the
nominees are the apprenticeship of
Donnie Kravitz screenplay by Mordecai
Richler the adaptation by Lionel
Chetwynd The Godfather Part 2 screenplay
by Francis Ford Coppola and Mario Puzo
Leni
screenplay by Julian Barratt Murder on
the Orient Express screenplay by Paul
Dean Young Frankenstein screenplay by
Gene Wilder and Mel Brooks
and the honored writer is Francis Ford
Coppola
where's Francis thank you very much and
I'd like to thank all the actors and
actresses in The Godfather both pictures
all three Godfather's for bringing the
book alive as I imagine it might be on
the screen thank you very much